we're being told by the media there's no
evidence
that there was any fraud in this
election obviously we've gone through
quite a bit of that evidence on this
show
but we saw some more evidence of that
last week last week during a
pennsylvania hearing
on some of the irregularities here you
had a data specialist
come out colonel phil waldron make even
more explosive claims than any of the
evidence we've been discussing on this
show
phil waldron claimed that the election
software that was used all around this
country
in great many places was built to be
hacked
the voting systems in the u.s and in
pennsylvania were built to be
manipulated
they've been used in elections around
the world um in stolen elections
around the world in venezuela italy
argentina singapore
bolivia as close as uh two weeks ago
the philadelphia uses esns pittsburgh
uses dominion
other counties in pennsylvania use
dominion
and other systems so what's what's the
real deal
so all these election systems have a
common dna
sgo smartmatic sold sequoia voting
systems to dominion in 2010
and then the divold company spun off
premier election systems to dominion
as a result of an anti-trust suit i know
there's been statements
to the contrary but i personally
debriefed the son of a cuban
intelligence officer
who had first-hand knowledge of hugo
chavez's family members who told him
not to worry about the populist threat
against maduro's election in venezuela
quote unquote that it was guaranteed
their father invested the money to build
the sgo
voting machine system so i have no
reason to doubt this gentleman he's uh
sworn in affidavit to this effect these
are pretty explosive claims
and before the media write this guy off
as some
total kook who heard this from a guy and
a guy and he's the
dry cleaner of the cousin of you know
this is a serious person
this colonel phil waldron talking about
serious people cuban intelligence
officers we know there's a very tight
relationship
between cuban intelligence and venezuela
particularly under
hugo chavez these claims are that
through various companies various sales
of companies there has been
some association between the different
election
software companies here notably dominion
and
that it was possible for the election to
have been hacked
that the that in a certain sense these
machines were built
such that the election could have been
hacked dominion of course
denies all of this i think it's pretty
clear that this guy's showing
vulnerabilities he's showing
he actually flat out states that the
devices are connected to the internet so
they have at least the logical
possibility of being hacked
the problem here though with running out
of time as president trump pointed out
is
the trump team needs to provide proof
not merely that this
could happen but that it did happen and
i know it's
very very difficult to provide that
proof
even if it did happen around the country
even if millions of votes were shifted
it would be very difficult to find the
proof of that
but the trump team needs to provide the
proof of that or
and this is just a purely descriptive
matter the courts are not going to
overthrow the election
and and frankly even the state
legislatures are not going to
flip the certification or refuse to
certify in the places that they haven't
it just won't happen they need to
provide the proof that it did
happen now look there is evidence we're
being told
there's no evidence of anything and even
let's forget about the poll watchers for
a second
there's no evidence that there were any
irregularities because of the voting
machines or batches of votes coming in
bs there's a ton of evidence of that in
fact colonel waldron points out that
there was a massive
vote dump while there have been massive
vote dumps in a number of places with
statistical anomalies
one of which showed that more than 99 of
the ballots in one dump
went to joe biden normally you would
expect to see
a smooth curve going up not any uh
not any big big spikes that's kind of
what
what greg was talking about the the
anomalies of loading
and uploading those those votes
so that big spike that occurs there
is a prime indicator of fraudulent
voting and that's 604
000 votes in 90 minutes is that right
correct this is uh 337 votes
337 000 votes in that uh
in that period of time yes and when you
look at this entire
curve with all these spikes
can you calculate how how much of a vote
that accounted for for biden
and how much for trump close to six
hundred thousand i think our our figures
are about 570 some odd thousand
that uh all those spikes represent over
time for but
correct and how much for trump i think
it was a little over 3 200.
570 000 for biden
3 000 for trump which means that in that
batch that came in
joe biden received 99.4
of the vote we got to congratulate joe
biden joe biden managed to outperform
saddam hussein at the height of his
power in iraq
in certain voting batch dumps
in certain counties in america wow good
job
joe here i thought that there was very
little enthusiasm for joe biden's
candidacy turns out
he does better numbers than a middle
eastern dictator does he or maybe maybe
not maybe he doesn't
maybe that's statistically impossible
did you miss out on our amazing black
friday deal
well we have a cure for your fomo that's
right today only
join us as a daily wire member for 50
off with code dw50 over at dailywire.com
subscribe since last year's deal we've
added so many more features and products
to our membership program
and we're extremely excited about it
we've added more exclusive readers past
content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content on apple tv and roku
which is huge
because we're adding more content every
day such as bringing you the michael
knowles show
five days a week starting friday
december 4th and
if you're an all access member you get
to join all access live
our exclusive daily live streams with me
or one of the other hosts
where we can talk to you directly about
just about anything and more importantly
where we can steal your ideas and use
them on the shows we offered this
incredible deal last year but we may not
be able to offer it again next year
so be sure to become a member today
using coupon code dw50
over at dailywire.com subscribe
[Music]
[Music]